[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis nordrhein westfalen hat gewählt
und damit herzlich willkommen und sport
gibt es mit norbert lehmann mit dem
spannenden aufstiegskampf in der zweiten
liga bremen hat es nach schalke direkt
geschafft aber als erstes schauen wir
auf das große thema heute die wahl im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
komfortabler vorsprung für wüst bei der
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen wird
seine cdu stärkste kraft an den grünen
führt nach rekordergebnis wohl kein weg
vorbei
zwei neue im klub trotz türkischer
skepsis steht aus sicht der nato dem
beitritt finnlands und schwedens nichts
mehr im weg finnland hat seine bewerbung
offiziell beschlossen
und politisch wie nie zuvor beim
eurovision song contest gewinnt die
ukraine klar weil die tv zuschauer sie
mit punkten überschüttet
die cdu liegt stand jetzt klar vorn bei
der landtagswahl in nordrhein-westfalen
verluste dagegen bei der spd den größten
zugewinn haben die grünen gemacht und
ihr bisher bestes ergebnis in dem
bundesland eingefahren bei fdp und afd
ist noch offen ob sie tatsächlich den
sprung über die fünf-prozent-hürde
schaffen schauen wir uns das alles in
zahlen an matthias fornoff in düsseldorf
hat die aktuelle hochrechnung für uns
matthias wie schneiden die parteien
genauer ja guten abend wir schauen uns
die neue hochrechnung an 19 uhr und
sehen dass die cdu hier auf 35,3 prozent
kommt klar stärkste partei ist die spd
27 5 die fdp mit kommt auf 5,5 und wäre
damit im landtag drin die afg mit
5,6 auch bei beiden muss man sagen die
briefwahl ergebnisse liegen noch nicht
vor es gibt noch ein kleines
fragezeichen
beide haben sich aber so stabilisiert
die grünen bei 17,9 prozent die linke
klar nicht im landtag 2,2 prozent und
andere zusammen 6 prozent jetzt gucken
wir mal auf gewinne und verluste die
waren erheblich die cdu kam von einem
starken ergebnis und legt noch einmal
mehr als zwei punkte zu die spd kam von
ihrem schlechtesten ergebnis überhaupt
in nrw und verliert noch mal 3,7 punkte
die fdp mehr als halbiert - 7,1 punkte
die afg mit verlusten minus 1,8 und die
grünen mit sehr großen zugewinnen 11,5
punkte im vergleich zur letzten
landtagswahl
die linke minus 2,7 vor fünf jahren
hatten sie 4,9 prozent waren knapp
gescheitert diesmal sind sie klar
draußen und wie sieht es nach
derzeitigem stand mit der sitzverteilung
aus welche koalition wenn möglich ja
schauen wir mal auf den düsseldorfer
landtag da rechnen wir mit 199 sitzen so
wie auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode und demnach käme die
cdu auf 76 sitze die spd auf 60 die fdp
auf 12 auch die afg auf 12 werden sie
beide drin sind und die grünen auf 39
sitze was heißt das für das regieren in
nordrhein westfalen und da es wichtig
diese senkrechte linie das ist die
absolute mehrheit die man braucht zum
regieren 100 sitze die derzeit
amtierende regierung cdu mit fdp 88
erreicht das deutlich nicht ist also
abgewählt schwarz-grün überschreitet
diese regel sehr deutlich 115 sitze 100
braucht man und das sehen wir hier spd
und grüne 99 da fehlt ein sitz kann sich
im laufe des abends natürlich noch
ändern spd grüne und fdp 111 auch das
würde deutlich reichen übrigens die
wahlbeteiligung ist deutlich gesunken um
9 punkte auf jetzt 56 prozent dank
matthias fornoff so sieht es also aus
nach der aktuellen hochrechnung die cdu
also stärkste kraft aber ob
ministerpräsident wies auch tatsächlich
die nächste regierung anführen wird ist
noch offen für schwarz grün würde es
reichen aber auch eine spd geführte
regierung wäre möglich und alle spitzen
kandidaten und eine kandidatin sind
jetzt in unserem zdf studio in
düsseldorf bei bettina schausten und
dort fertig jetzt übergeben
vielen dank jana und wir beginnen mit
dem cdu-ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst
ja jetzt die chance hat das auch zu
bleiben schönen guten abend also die cdu
bleibt stärkste kraft aber wir haben es
gesehen schwarz-gelb ihre regierung ist
abgewählt wie wollen sie es schaffen
jetzt die grünen ins boot zu holen
während sehr dankbar für dieses starke
ergebnis meiner partei wie lägen noch
einmal zu ganz klar stärkste partei und
damit auch ein klarer regierungsauftrag
ein klarer auftrag eine neue regierung
zu bilden und zu führen und ich werde
auf alle demokratischen parteien zugehen
um eine neue eine starke regierung zu
bilden die in der lage ist mit mit den
themen dieser zeit aber auch mit der
besonders schwierigen situation aktuell
wegen des kriegs in der ukraine
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen
thomas kutschaty spitzenkandidat der spd
das schlechteste ergebnis für die
sozialdemokratie nordrhein westfalen als
armin laschet ähnliches im bund
vergangenes jahr passiert ist für die
christdemokraten haben sie gesagt ist
eine anmaßung darauf den auftrag zur
regierungsbildung abzuleiten was gilt
denn jetzt sie erstmal glückwunsch an
cdu und grüne das sind die beiden
parteien die zugelegt haben respekt und
komplimente dafür insbesondere auch
richtung grüner ist ein sensationell
gutes ergebnis für die grünen was aber
auch feststeht ist schwarz-gelb ist
abgewählt wurde und wir müssen schauen
wie es jetzt eine neue mehrheit hier im
nordrhein westfälischen landtag geben
kann die verlässlich auch die
zukunftsaufgaben lösen kann und da muss
man schon schauen wer spricht jetzt mit
wem wir sind bereit gespräche hier
aufzuführen in nordrhein westfalen um
mitglieder einer fortschritts regierung
auch zu werden darauf kommt jetzt in den
nächsten tagen an und lassen sie uns
jetzt erstmal abwarten welche mehrheiten
oder konstellation überhaupt möglich
sind das liegt ja gerade noch alles sehr
sehr eng beieinander nun erneut die
spitzenkandidatin der grünen die grünen
sind die größten gewinner heute abend
sie haben ihr ergebnis fast verdreifacht
und sind jetzt königsmacher frau
neubauer haben die qual der wahl
zusammen mit cdu oder spd sie werden uns
heute nicht verraten aber was sind die
kriterien nach denen sie entscheiden
werden wir sind im wahlkampf als grüne
eigenständig und sie muss aufgetreten
und wurde offensichtlich dafür gewählt
dass wir gesagt haben wir brauchen in
nordrhein westfalen eine landesregierung
die endlich auf der höhe der zeit agiert
also da wo menschen in nordrhein
westfalen oder die wirtschaft längst ist
und dafür haben wir das vertrauen
bekommen deswegen vielen dank an die die
uns das vertrauen ausgesprochen
dieser vertrauensvorschuss ist jetzt was
wo wir mit respekt arbeiten werden
weiterhin hart arbeiten werden hier in
nordrhein westfalen und für die inhalte
die bedeutung ist es die aufgabe dieser
politischen generation die klimakrise zu
bekämpfen und dabei den lastenausgleich
in der belastung so zu verteilen dass es
fair zugeht in nordrhein-westfalen und
dadurch den zusammenhalt für die
menschen in unserem starken und
vielfältigen land zu gerieren das ist
nicht weniger als das war das was wir im
wahlkampf vertreten haben eigenständig
und das werden wir jetzt in den
kommenden gesprächen mit den
demokratischen parteien auch machen
im stamm von der fdp sie haben ihr
wahlergebnis von 2017 fast halbiert
können sie denn daraus überhaupt einen
auftrag ziehen an irgendeiner
regierungskoalition dann teilzuhaben ich
glaube die frage stellt sich heute abend
gar nicht sondern wir sind in einer
situation wo wir eine ganz schwere
niederlage haben hinnehmen müssen und
das werden wir auch in aller
gründlichkeit
aufarbeiten und der glückwunsch geht
dann die wahl gewinner des heutigen
abends und ansonsten werden wir uns
darauf konzentrieren jetzt zunächst
einmal zu analysieren woran es gelegen
hat dass wir nicht in der lage waren
unsere wählerinnen und wähler so zu
mobilisieren wie wir uns das vorgestellt
die auch ihre partei hat verluste erneut
nach kiel was heißt dass wir die partei
im westen deutschlands
für uns heißt das zunächst mal dass wir
bei unserem zweiten wahl antritt in
nordrhein westfalen zum zweiten mal in
den landtag eingezogen sind das ist
historisch in der parteiengeschichte
nordrhein westfalens noch nie dagewesen
zum anderen ist es so dass ich gerade
der wahlkampf in den letzten zwei wochen
insbesondere auf das duell cdu/spd
zugespitzt hat darunter leiden kleine
parteien die sp die fdp hat das heute
sehr schmerzlich erwischt die linke
spielt keine rolle mehr wir haben auch
verluste hinnehmen müssen aber wir haben
uns insgesamt konsolidiert und wir
können stolz darauf sein zum zweiten mal
hintereinander in den landtag eingezogen
zu sein wahlerfolg für sie herr wüste
ist jetzt daniel günther oder hendrik
wüst für die cdu der größte
hoffnungsträger in der zukunft heute
geht es um nordrhein-westfalen wie wir
mit respekt und anstand jetzt mit so
einem wahlergebnis umgehen und auf der
anderen seite auch die weichen stellen
die großen fragen unserer zeit zu
beantworten in diesem industrieland ist
die transformation die größte
herausforderung also klimaschutz und
gute arbeitsplätze in der industrie
dauerhaft miteinander zu verbinden das
ist jetzt die aufgabe und darum ging es
schließen wir die runde hier aus
nordrhein westfalen aus düsseldorf
direkt zurück nach mainz vielen dank an
bettina schausten und dort ferber als
bevölkerungsreichstes bundesland hat die
wahl in nrw eine besondere
bundespolitische bedeutung schauen wir
daher jetzt auf die ersten reaktionen
der parteien in der hauptstadt berlin
stärkste kraft heißt für uns
verantwortung zu übernehmen
verantwortung für nordrhein westfalen
verantwortlich verantwortlich zu sein
für eine verlässliche zukunfts regierung
in nordrhein westfalen für die menschen
dort und diese verlässliche regierung
wollen wir dort schmieden natürlich
haben wir für ein besseres ergebnis
gekämpft allerdings hat sich ja die
prozentzahl die wir jetzt bekommen und
mal gucken wie die entwicklung am abend
sind aber sieht danach aus dass wir
zweiter kraft werden und das hat sich ja
angedeutet in den letzten tagen und
gleichwohl muss man ja sagen steht noch
nichts fest für nordrhein westfalen
außer dass die amtierende
landesregierung die schwarz gelbe
landesregierung abgewählt wurde nach
schleswig-holstein letzte woche haben
wir heute in nordrhein westfalen unter
historisch bestes ergebnis erzielt das
zeigt dass die menschen wahrnehmen dass
wir antworten auf der höhe der zeit
haben und dass wir bereit sind die
zukunft zu gestalten und es zeigt auch
dass sie uns gerade in nordrhein
westfalen in der regierung sehen wollen
und wollen dass wir dort
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen wir
sind erstmal zufrieden ist aller
voraussicht nach doch reicht das wir
einziehen werden also dafür auch einmal
herzlichen dank an unsere wähler wir
haben viele neue gesichter die in den
landtag einziehen wären also es wird
weiter eine alternative hier im landtag
geben das ist wichtig gleichwohl sind
wir natürlich in gänze nicht zufrieden
da werden wir uns die nächsten tage
natürlich auch unterhalten müssen
inwieweit wir jedoch eine initiative
west auch hier brauchen das ist eine
schwere niederlage und das schmerzt
gerade ich glaube alle freidemokraten
aber gerade die freien demokraten und
freidemokrat innen die wie ich auch in
den letzten tagen und wochen sich in
dieser kampagne besonders organisiert
haben engagiert haben und organisiert
haben und da muss man einfach anerkennen
dass das kein guter abend für uns ist
und weitere informationen zur
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen
sowie die berliner runde mit den im
bundestag vertretenen parteien können
sie gleich nach dieser sendung sehen und
zahlen und hintergründe natürlich auch
jederzeit online in der zdf- heute
blicken wir jetzt auf den ukraine krieg
und seine weitreichenden folgen die nato
wird wohl größer finnland hat heute
offiziell beschlossen eine
mitgliedschaft zu beantragen auch
schwedens regierungspartei will einen
beitritt trotz kritischer töne aus der
türkei geht nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg davon aus dass sich der
beitrittsprozess nicht verzögern werde
andreas künast über das treffen der nato
außenminister in und minister in berlin
es kommt drauf an heute auf die
gastgeberin auf jedes wort man sieht der
deutschen außenministerin die gefahr
regelrecht an die plötzlich über dem
berliner gipfel schwebt das ihr
türkischer kollege aus dem großen nato
fest ein großes scheitern macht will und
muss berbalk verhindern schweden und
finnland sind nicht nur unsere partner
nicht nur unsere freunde sondern sie
sind bereits seit langen unsere
europäischen familienmitgliedern das zur
30-köpfigen nato familie zwei neue köpfe
dazu kommen wollen steht seit heute fest
in helsinki iv beschließt die regierung
den beitrittsantrag zu stellen
wir haben heute einen historischen tag
finnland wird seine sicherheit
maximieren
und auch in stockholm spricht sich
ministerpräsidentin andersen vor einer
stunde für die nato-mitgliedschaft aus
dass das bündnis nicht feiert in berlin
dass es kracht wie seit jahren nicht
liegt an der türkei gestern abend gerät
der türkische aussenminister heftig mit
seiner schwedischen amtskollegin
aneinander ihr start sei eine heimstatt
für terroristen
ein türkisches jahr zum beitritt knüpft
cavusoglu an bedingungen die bekämpfung
der pkk ist eine davon ein außenminister
nach dem anderen redet auf den türken
ein ergebnis es bleibt schwierig
was die unterschiede zwischen der türkei
schweden und finnland angeht wir haben
gesprochen es gibt weitere gespräche und
eine zuversicht bis es zur abstimmung
kommt muss es konsens geben
in deutschland soll der beitritt nicht
scheitern berbalk kündigt einen
schnellen kabinettsbeschluss und eine
sondersitzung des bundestags an
und nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
äußerte sich auch zur russischen
invasion der ukraine moskau erreiche
seine ziele nicht die ukraine könne den
krieg gewinnen besonders im osten des
landes dauern die erbitterten kämpfe an
auch um das belagerte stahlwerken mario
pohl alexandra vacano die hölle ist auf
die erde gekommen so der stadtrat von
mario pohl und veröffentlicht dieses
video ein feuerregen über dem azoff
stahlwerk in dem noch ukrainische
soldaten eingekesselt sind die russen
hätten das mit phosphorbomben beschossen
heißt es von ukrainischer seite
unabhängig bestätigen lässt sich das
nicht aber russland spricht inzwischen
von brandt auslösenden bomben diese
zivilisten konnten sich auf eigene faust
durchschlagen raus aus mario pohl einen
konvoi von 500 bis 1000 autos mit
geflüchteten ist gestern in sapporo
angekommen nach einer langen odyssee
sicher es war hart die leute haben
vorher schon hatte dinge durchgemacht
sie waren nervös die reise war
verheerend aber das war es wert
erfolge vermeldet kiew rundum hackl die
russen hätten sich zurückgezogen jetzt
sichern hier wieder ukrainische soldaten
die dörfer und die menschen kehren in
ihre völlig zerstörten häuser zurück
weiterhin hart gekämpft wird im donbass
im donbass ist die lage nach wie vor
sehr schwierig russische truppen
versuchen immer noch zumindest eine art
sieg zu zeigen am achtzigsten tag der
groß angelegten invasion scheint es
besonders verstörend zu sein aber sie
hören nicht auf
und das britische
verteidigungsministerium twittert heute
in seinem lagebericht russland ist es im
vergangenen monat nicht gelungen
nennenswerte gebietsgewinne zu erzielen
russland hat jetzt wahrscheinlich
verluste von einem drittel der
bodenkampf truppe erlitten
trümmer des krieges auch an diesem tag
und lange noch kein frieden in sicht
nach deutschland auch im zweiten corona
jahr hat die häusliche gewalt erneut
zugenommen die landeskriminalämter
zählten 161.000 opfer ein plus von 1,3
prozent das berichtet die welt am
sonntag zwei drittel der opfer waren
frauen weiß ging die gewalt von partnern
oder ex partnern aus die zahlen könnten
noch weit höher liegen denn die polizei
geht von einer hohen dunkelziffer aus
entsetzen in den usa bei einem offenbar
rassistischen anschlags in zehn menschen
getötet und drei weitere verletzt worden
die mehrzahl der opfer war schwarz der
18-jährige weiße täter hatte in der
stadt buffalo im bundesstaat new york in
einem supermarkt das feuer eröffnet er
wurde festgenommen und wegen mordes
angeklagt
us präsident biden sprach den opfern und
angehörigen sein mitgefühl aus und sagte
dem inlands teurer den kampf an
matthiesen
es sind szenen wie nach einem
terroranschlag menschen getötet als sie
im supermarkt einkaufen wollten an
diesem nachmittag schrecken leid trauer
über eine tat die amerika erschüttert
weil ein weißer rassist das feuer
eröffnete
er erschoss seine frau dann einen
priester wieder eine frau dann ging er
rein und schoss weiter
zehn tote drei weitere menschen wurden
verletzt der schütze hatte
halbautomatische waffen mengen von
munition als die polizei eintraf ergab
sich der 18-jährige dayton g beschert
der schütze ist stundenlang hierher
gefahren um dieses verbrechen an den
menschen von buffalo zu begehen
er stammt aus einem kleinen ort mehr als
300 kilometer entfernt sein ziel wählte
er weil der anteil der schwarzen
bevölkerung in diesem bezirk am größten
ist so schreibt er in seinem
rassistischen antisemitischen hass
pamphlet im internet er glaubt an eine
verschwörungstheorie vom angeblichen
austausch der weißen bevölkerung gegen
andere ethnien die tat trägt alle
merkmale von terrorismus rassistisch und
politisch motiviert die lüge vom
bevölkerungsaustausch wird von
rechtsextremen kommentatoren und
politikern in den usa in europa und auch
in deutschland verbreitet die trauer
vereint die menschen in buffalo und die
erinnerung an die opfer unter ihnen zwei
frauen 86 und 77 jahre alt die sich
besonders um die armen in ihrer stadt
gekümmert haben
im libanon haben die menschen heute ein
neues parlament gewählt mitten in der
wohl schwersten krise des landes kaum
jobs immens steigende preise und auch
die folgen der explosionskatastrophe im
hafen von beirut vor knapp zwei jahren
hat das land nicht überwunden viele
libanesen setzen deshalb eigentlich auf
einen wechsel dennoch rechnen
beobachterinnen und beobachter damit
dass die von iran gestützte hisbollah
partei erneut stärkste kraft werden
könnte einerseits gilt die opposition
als schlecht organisiert andererseits
sollen stimmen gekauft worden seien
eine knallbunte party mit schrägen
outfits und vielen emotionen das ist der
eurovision songcontest und politisch
soll der esc sein so die vorgabe aber an
diesem jahr kam es anders denn gewonnen
hat die ukraine mit dem kammerorchester
nie zuvor hat ein ex so viele punkte von
den zuschauenden bekommen die klare
botschaft europa steht zusammen über ein
abend mit schrillen auftritten großen
stimme und noch mehr symbolik berichtet
annette hilsenbeck
wird diese chips der wunsch nach frieden
es ist ein ungewöhnlicher anfang der
zeigt dieser eurovision songcontest es
anders es geht nicht nur um musik
[Applaus]
das überwältigende votum der zuschauer
lief dann die band carlos orchestra zum
sieg 12 punkte aus fast jedem land
höchst wird jemals zeichen für frieden
und demokratie für den song stéphanie
[Applaus]
vorsprung nicht der mutter des sängers
gewidmet empfinden ukraine den song
inzwischen als firma auf ihrer heimat
der musikalische triumph für sie wichtig
vielen dank danke dass ihr die ukraine
unterstützt dieser sieht es für jeden
ukraine nun der ukraine
der sc in diesem jahr hoch politische
statements auf der bühne sind laut
regelwerk nicht erlaubt und werden doch
geduldet fans und die musiker der
anderen länder zeigen ihre solidarität
in blau gelb
hinter dem kammerorchester konnten sich
großbritannien und spanien platzieren
deutschland landete mit malic harris auf
dem letzten platz
die ukraine aber ist gewinner des esc
dazu veröffentlichte der ukrainische
präsident see lenski ein post in
sozialen medien
unser mut beeindruckt die welt unserer
musik erobert europa im nächsten jahr
empfängt die ukraine den eurovision
die mitglieder von carlos orchestra
müssen in zwei tagen nach hause den
musikalischen klang farbe nehmen sie mit
um die solidarität europas
[Applaus]
man jetzt kommen wir zum sport mit
norbert norbert gestern super spannung
mehr an der ersten bundesliga jetzt den
fußball kaminer zweiten ja das ganze so
laut sagen schalke stand ja bereits als
aufsteiger fest aber wer begleitet
königsblau direkt in liga eins bremen
darmstadt und hamburg hatten die chance
genutzt hat sie werde marvin duksch traf
in der 51 minute zum 2 0-endstand im
heimspiel gegen regensburg bremen
verteilt damit tabellenplatz zwei
direkter wiederaufstieg von werder in
die bundesliga ja und dann der hsv
mittel kaufmanns schoss die hamburger in
der 85 minute in rostock zum 3 2 sieg
dank des besseren torverhältnisses
schaffte es der hsv so auf den
relegationsplatz trauer statt dessen in
darmstadt trotz des 13 und heimsiegs der
lilien gegen paderborn blieb am ende nur
der undankbare vierte platz darmstadt
zwar punktgleich mit dem hsv aber im mit
dem schlechteren torverhältnis und dann
schauen wir jetzt mal wie in bremen
dieser sieg gefeiert wurde
statt musikern in grün-weiß nicht
gegeizt mit euphorie wird heute bei den
hanseaten
wiederaufstieg nach nur einem jahr
zweite liga
wir sind wieder in der ersten bundesliga
dreht muss erstklassig ja meister werden
wer sonst wenn dich wir auf jeden fall
mit ole werner schaffen wir das große
träume in bremen große erleichterung in
hamburg der hsv kann noch aufsteigen
ich hoffe wir geben nicht auf und wir
biegen das noch das eine oder andere
spiel haben ja auch noch gewürgt als
auch außen immer wieder hoffnung ist
egal wir steigen jetzt
treffen sie auf die hsv ikone felix
magath der in der relegation versucht
hertha in der liga zu halten in hamburg
heißt es zuversicht tangeln
ja noch ein trainer abgang in der
bundesliga zum saisonende wolfsburg
coach florian coesfeld verlässt den vfl
nach nur sieben monaten tätigkeit im
verein
und wer hat heute neben bremen und
hamburg auch noch was zu feiern ja der
fc bayern über 10.000 fans bejubelten
auf den münchner marienplatz ihren
deutschen meister der zum zehnten mal in
folge die schale gewinnen konnte und sie
skandierten in sprechchören lieber bleib
lieber bleibt an die adresse von
stürmerstar robert lewandowski der
möglicherweise schon zur nächsten saison
den fcb verlassen hat
ja und er hat auch was zu feiern jürgen
klopp und sein fc liverpool haben den
englischen fa-cup gewonnen nach torlosen
120 minuten im pokalfinale gegen chelsea
fiel die entscheidung im
elfmeterschießen
liverpools torwart ellison becker
pariert den schuss von chelsea stürmer
mason mount direkt danach der
siegtreffer für die red zum 6 5 durch
constantinos ziemlich kasse
und erstmals was zu feiern hatte die
deutsche eishockey mannschaft gestern
abend bei der wm in finnland nach der
auftaktniederlage gegen weltmeister
kanada ein überraschender sieg gegen die
slowakei leo prödl erzielt den treffer
zur 2 0 führung für deutschland danach
der anschlusstreffer von christian
pospischil dank des starken torwarts
philipp grubauer blieb es am ende beim
deutschen 2 zu 1 volk und
morgen an das dritte deutsche
gruppenspiel gegen frankreich danke
nachweise werden wir noch einen kurzen
blick aufs wetter morgen ist es östlich
der weser und in ostbayern freundlich
sonst ziehen von westen schauer und
gewitter auf ist drohen unwetter mit
starkregen die temperatur erreicht 20
bis 28 an der ostsee 17 grad
um die landtagswahl in nrw geht es
natürlich auch um 21 45 im heute journal
mit marietta slomka und mit unserer
sondersendung zur wahl machen wir jetzt
auch direkt weiter ich übergebe an
bettina schausten